bonjour à tous et merci de nous
retrouver pour ce nouveau numéro du 7-8
week-end tout de suite le sommaire de ce
vendredi 8 juillet jean-emmanuel
charreaux administrateur du château de
breteuil nous présente en plateau les
nouveautés pour les vacances ainsi que
les deux nouveau chef-d'oeuvre en
exposition le groupe est fort vient
illuminer les jardins de l'orangerie du
château de versailles avec son grand
spectacle pyrotechnique louis xiv le roi
de feu il reste encore deux dates
exceptionnelles pour le découvrir les 14
et 15 juillet 25 août au responsable
événementiel de l'île des loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines
invité également de cette émission et
nous parlera de l'ouverture du village
d'été sportifs et des différents
événements programmés pour l'été
jean emmanuel charlot bonjour alors je
le disais vous êtes administrateur du
château de breteuil
on va parler ensemble du programme de
cet été on présentera les deux
nouveautés
fraîchement exposé à partir de dimanche
décompte quotidien pour cet été contes
de perrault tout à fait alors le château
tout d'abord est ouvert tous les jours
de l'été le parc ouvre à 10 heures il y
à une première visite guidée le matin
11h30 et ensuite tout l'après midi tous
les jours à 16 heures 30 il y à une
conteuse qui va raconter trois histoires
de charles perrault pendant une heure
aux enfants et à leurs parents grands
parents c'est un public très familial
le tout à fait tout à fait hélas les
conteuses ont un grand succès qui
complète bien le travail que l'admirable
que font les guides conférenciers dans
la visite guidée du château
la visite guidée du château se sont
aussi 50 personnages de cire du musée
grévin qui raconte d'une façon très
agréable très ludique l'histoire de
france à travers l'histoire d'une
famille le château est entièrement
meublé donc c'est très agréable de
revisiter ce genre de château chaleureux
je dirais oui les deux sont
complémentaires tout à fait vitale avec
le conquérant demain complète bien
l'autre voilà c'est effectivement pour
une sortie complète il ya la côte et le
côté historique
et puis le côté très féerique des contes
de perrault alors il ya vraiment donc on
peut aussi bien visiter le château dans
son intérieur que par les beaux jours le
jardin le jardin il y a un très beau
labyrinthe avec mille bruits qui ont été
plantés ce labyrinthe un très grand
succès un terrain de jeu également pour
les enfants dans le parc il ya un
colombier médiévale qui a été
entièrement restauré et puis dans toutes
les dépendances du château les écuries
le lavoir le fruitiers etc
vous retrouvez des contes de perrault il
y en a huit au total qui sont mises en
scène
vous avez barbe-bleue dans la salle de
chasse par exemple terrifiant menaçant
de tuer sa dernière femme
il y à cendrillon qui prend son carrosse
pour aller au bal
vous en retrouverez 8 comme ceci est
tout un parcours à faire au moins deux
heures je dirais de promenade dans le
parc
sans compter le temps passé sur le
terrain de jeu et au moins deux heures
dans le parc une heure dans la visite
guidée du château une heure avec la
conteuse
si vous voulez pique-niqué vous pouvez
arriver d'elle
atteint il ya un kiosque crêperie qui
est ouvert tous les jours sauf le samedi
et tous les jours de l'été sur le
terrain de jeu vous pouvez avoir les
croque monsieur madame des galettes des
crêpes des glaces externe donc un lieu
historique si tu va s'animer et prendre
hui tout au long de l'été il y aura
également deux spectacles un premier
notamment dimanche 10 juillet avec une
troupe costumée et celui laisse une
surprise n'était pas prévu c'est vrai
dimanche donc dans deux jours nous
aurons une troupe costumée qui va venir
jouer différentes saynètes qui se passe
à l'époque de louis saez et de
marie-antoinette donc de très beaux
costumes et des petites mises en scène
comme ceux ci dans le parc pour le
divertissement de nos visiteurs il n'y a
aucun supplément pour ce genre
d'activités qui étaient effectivement un
prévu un cadeau pour votre public
également un deuxième rendez vous c'est
le dimanche 21 août concert à des
petites mains symphoniques ce sera à
15h30 tout à fait dans la cour d'honneur
du château il y a trois cents enfants de
3 à 17 ans qui sont tous des virtuoses
et qu'ils vont jouer pendant une bonne
heure plusieurs petits cons sorti dans
la cour d'honneur
alors vous parliez tout à l'heure des
visites liées au circuit à l'intérieur
du château
il y a deux nouveautés qui vont revenir
au château à partir de dimanche
la table de breteuil et le mobilier du
salon de l'art elle tout à fait alors la
table de breteuil c'est une réplique de
la fameuse table de breteuil qui
maintenant exposée au louvre mais qui a
été exposée au château jusqu'à jusqu'à
ce qu'elles soient vendues au louvre
l'an dernier cette table a toujours fait
partie du mobilier du château on a fait
faire une réplique pour pouvoir
continuer en raconter l'histoire
elle racontait l'histoire du du baron de
breteuil qui avait reçu cette table à
l'époque de louis saez pour son rôle
médiatique il avait rétabli la paix en
europe et donc elle est reçue cette
table somptueux c'est une table bijoux
vraiment admirable et la réplique est
aussi belle que l'original effectivement
sur un des médaillons en porcelaine de
meissen il y à une dédicace à breteuil
missionnaires de la paix 1579 oui c'est
un cadeau somptueux qu'il avait reçu à
l'époque
l'autre nouveauté également thème de
mobilier c'est une exposition du très
beau salon
fable de la fontaine parce qu'il ya les
fables sur les tapisseries des sièges un
mobilier complet avec un très beau
canapé des bergères fauteuil et grande
cheminée et ça fait un très très bel
ensemble dans une bibliothèque du
château des visites des comptes a
retrouvé donc tout l'été tous les jours
de cet été avec la conteuse à 16h30 au
château de breteuil
merci beaucoup je me suis d'abord et on
vous souhaite alors un très bel été au
château
merci bientôt alors on poursuit
également avec un autre lieu historique
qui s'anime avec le grand spectacle
pyrotechnique louis xiv le roi de feu
qui revient pour de nouvelles dates en
juillet ce soir vendredi 8 jeudi 14 et
vendredi 15 pour l'occasion le roi
soleil lui-même et metteur en scène du
spectacle et nous transporte à travers
de multiples tableaux composés de vidéos
de feu et de lumière
véritable maître des artifices le groupe
f réinvente le faste des fêtes
extraordinaire des jardins du roi soleil
avec son grand spectacle pyrotechnique
louis xiv le roi de feu artificiers et
comédien les professionnels du groupe f
organise depuis 25 ans les plus grands
spectacles pyrotechniques à travers le
monde comme les feux du 14 juillet le
passage à l'an 2000 ou encore les coupes
du monde de football et de rugby au
groupe f on est tous artificiers avant
tout donc on arrive ya un feu a monté il
ya quelque chose derrière et un feu
d'artifice donc on y est tous très
souvent et n'ad'autre vraiment les
techniciens ils sont sur une période
plus longue mais
comédien quand on arrive on y participe
un peu sur la fin ensuite on montre
montrent nos propres structures ce qu'on
joue ce qu'on joue sur le plateau tout
ce qu'on porte sur le dos dans les mains
là c'est nous qui me monte ont pendant
une heure un enchaînement de tableaux
sur la thématique des planètes
orchestrée par le roi soleil lui même
pour illustrer son pouvoir suprême à
travers l'évocation du dieu mars et la
guerre le dieu apollon et sa beauté ou
encore jupiter souverain des dieux le
spectacle met les moyens croiser des
flammes des feux d'artifice de la vidéo
et des personnages lumineuse et porteur
de feu pour donner enfin du corps à ses
personnages on est rembourré et ça
permet aussi de porter nos batteries
toutes les antennes qui nous met en
communication avec la régie et voilà
parce qu'en fait on est piloté par par
la région on peut s'allumer nous tous
seuls mais pendant le spectacle c'est
pas nous qui nous allumons le spectacle
se termine par un final sont que lorsque
leroy finit par retrouver son astre le
soleil représentant sa puissance sur
tous et sa gloire universelle
alors on va continuer à parler du
programme de cet été parce que c'est
saint quentin en yvelines qui s'anime en
ce moment pour fêter l'été avec vous
alors avec vous thérèse mallem bonjour
vous êtes adjointe à la communication du
maire de magny les hameaux et à la
démocratie locale
je sais que vous y tenez melodia tahir
vous êtes responsable de la maison
auguste renoir maison cartier de
guyancourt et enfin vincent couteau
responsable événementiel de l'île des
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
alors on va démarrer avec la 7e édition
de remets tes tongs ça se passe jusqu'au
14 juillet à magny les hameaux
cette année la thématique ce sont les
légumes bio et c'est toujours en lien
avec l'unesco exactement donc nous avons
choisi de suivre encore l'unesco pour
l'année internationale 2016 sur les
légumineuses voilà et donc beaucoup
d'ateliers ont été mis en place pour
apprendre aux enfants à préparer des
plats des brochettes de légumes de
fruits
comment utiliser les restes mais ça
c'est très important travail sur le non
gaspillage de l'alimentation de la
nourriture beaucoup de choses sont faits
par les associations de magny les
hameaux et les tous les jeunes publics
alors ce soir vendredi 8 c'est un temps
fort un temps fort parmi les temps forts
de cet événement et donc il y a
également d un travail mené avec les
producteurs et commerçants locaux
c'est ça découvre ton terroir donc il va
commencer à 17 heures cet après midi
donc il y aura beaucoup d'associations
et d'agriculteurs qui vont venir exposer
toujours sur la place gérard philipe au
quartier du buisson donc justement
qu'ils vont proposer leurs produits
locaux pour montrer c'est d'ailleurs
pour l'événement il ya quarante
partenaires qu'avant de partenaires qui
nous ont aidés à préparer cette
opération cet événement qui est toujours
un succès est très apprécié de la
population manie croates ont très belle
émission alors toujours par rapport aux
précédentes éditions on retrouve les
intérêts jeune public vous en parliez
donc cette année c'est lié aux
gaspillages au losc il est ce qu'on peut
se faire avec les fruits légumes on a un
atelier
de masquer la création de la création
avec des légumes et des fruits
donc ils ont se sont basés sur un
peintre italien assure bild aux actions
boldo pas facile à dire qu'ils qui crée
donc ses portraits sur le suggérer par
des légumes et donc les enfants ou ses
des masques qui utiliseront demain pour
un défilé demain après midi qui sera
aussi un temps fort sur manier l'amour
toujours des structures sportives et des
activités manuelles exactement la
structure gonflable parcours aventure
les enfants moines toujours des des
animations zumba aussi et aussi de la
musique la danse ça c'est quelque chose
que tout le monde avait des sénateurs
très fédérateur mais c'est ce qu'on
cherche donc vous parliez tout à l'heure
du temps fort justement avec les
producteurs et commerçants locaux
mais ce n'est pas tout il ya également
un théâtre en plein exactement donc à
18h30 il aura le théâtre en plein air
donc la troupe de théâtre de qui
joue actuellement aux portes du temps
aussitôt port de port royal vient
spécialement à magny les hameaux que
nous faire cette représentation qu'on
espère un succès fou également il y aura
du cinéma voilà 22h30 séance planaire
ratatouille toujours sous le thème
culinaire des initiations de partir vous
en parlais tout à l'heure avec les
ombres à la zumba donc il ya eu aussi
plus tranquille plus zen du tai-chi
voilà demain
il ya aussi du foot futsal et bien sûr
la retransmission et la revoilà des
mobiles 17 6 heures avec le bonheur que
la france ait gagné je le mets en plus
que je le place c'est tellement beau
tellement bien venir bon alors
exactement est également cette année
pour des raisons économiques voilà nous
avons supprimé notre feu d'artifice est
remplacé par un banquet républicain donc
voilà parce qu'il ya un code un code
drees on souhaiterait que les électeurs
sa vie en bleu blanc rouge
et puis donc c'est vrai dans l'événement
rtt on l'a un peu aussi appelé un pique
nique musical puisqu'il y aura aussi une
troupe musicale qui viendra animer
animer cette manifestation
donc chacun apportera un plat parce que
ça aussi il faut bien le savoir c'est
que chaque et béton vient avec un plan
qu'il a préparé lui-même
c'est vraiment dans un esprit de partage
égalité de partage exactement donc
remets tes tongs et c'est un événement
qui prend vie à magny les hameaux et
donc ce serait jusqu'au 14 juillet vous
avez un coup de coeur spéciales vont re
l'un des temps forts de cet événement
alors moi je dirais peut-être la pièce
de théâtre de ce soir voilà l a pas
encore eu lieu mais je pense que ça sera
un beau spectacle très bien on y sera
merci madame alors on continue avec
guyancourt billancourt pour fêter l'été
a décidé donc c'est une première une
scène ouverte pourquoi est-ce que vous
avez opté pour une scène ouverte est
bien pour mettre en avant les talents
des guyancourt toit notamment des jeunes
on a fait un partenariat avec le service
jeunesse pour pouvoir accueillir des
talents sur une scène et donner la
possibilité de s'exprimer
et puis
tout un événement festif autour c'est
aussi une forme de restitution
d'ateliers parce que là vous parlez des
stages de rap qui ont eu lieu il y a
trois rappeurs qui seront présents à la
scène ouverte de ce soir c'est ça en
fait il ya un stage qui a été organisée
avec le service jeunesse c'est un
rappeur qui s'appelle mom c'est donc
c'est un rappeur local et donc ils ont
ils se sont entraînés tous ensemble à
être réagir avec le public à se déplacer
sur scène et donc là ça va être la
partie pratique la partie où la falloir
bien bien engagée ce qui a été pas ce
qui a été appris pendant pendant le
stage donc donc voilà ça va être pour
une bonne petite pression mais bon c'est
la scène donc c'est normal
cette scène ouverte c'est une mise à
l'honneur des talents amateurs guéant
courtois ces chats donc avec donc ces
trois rappeurs il y aura aussi deux
guitaristes et de groupes de danse de
l'association uefa qui vont aussi mettre
leurs talents en avant devant on espère
un public nombreux et très festif mais
bon comme le disait madame vu la
victoire hier je pense que les gens sont
assez festif en ce moment donc ça
témoigne on sent une nièce collégiale
alors pas d'humour par contre est-ce que
vous avez pour autant des amateurs aux
deux one man show qui se sont inscrits
ou pas non malheureusement je pense que
c'est le fait que ce soit la première
édition effectivement c'est pas encore
quelque chose qui est un peu connu mais
bon on va s'atteler à cette tâche pour
l'année prochaine et s'est trouvé plus
des humoristes et s'est diversifié
peut-être un peu plus sa demande sur sur
cet événement donc la scène ouverte pour
fêter l'été à guyancourt elle est sur le
parvis de la maison
auguste renoir à partir de 18h30 et à
partir de 20h vous convier tous les
locaux à venir danser et un dj amina
animera pardon la piste de danse c'est
ça alors juste petite correction s'est
pas partir de 18h sont faits à partir de
18 heures elle met un peu de temps donc
à partir c'est noté l'ouverture de la
scène ouverte sur le parvis de la maison
auguste renoir et donc le du dia par
contre 20 heures ça c'est bon c'est bon
donc à juste derrière mon petit speech
documents sont arrivés 18h30 c'est pas
très grave mais
mais voilà et après donc de 20h à 22h
donc c'est un dj aussi localisé julien
gauthier il est pas guyancourt toinon en
tout cas il est déjà présent sur sur
l'année et il mène des activités avec
votre maison pour l'instant non mais
effectivement comme c'est une première
collaboration on verra comment ça se
passait effectivement peut-être
développer des choses peut-être plus à
long terme
effectivement sur la ville proposait des
stages dj ou autre vous pensez déjà à la
deuxième édition
justement on y réfléchit pour faire
parce qu'en fait c'est donc ça se passe
à la maison cartier mais effectivement
c'est un rayonnement sur toute la ville
donc effectivement peut-être voir ce
qu'on peut faire pour ben se faire que
ça soit un événement assez régulier et
on l'espère sur plusieurs années et
fiction merci beaucoup melodia derrière
d'être venu nous présenter donc la
première édition de la fête de l'été à
guyancourt
vincent couteau on continue avec vous
avec l'ouverture du village sportif
aline des loisirs ça y est c'est ouvert
donc ce sont des activités sportives
gratuites pour les jeunes de 11 à 17 ans
il faut passer par le biais d'une
inscription par les maisons de quartier
centre de jeunesse de tf1 on accueille
toutes les structures qui qui veulent
emmener des jeunes de 11 à 17 ans sur ce
village financée par le conseil régional
d'île de france et c'est un village avec
vraiment une multitude d'activités qu'on
retrouve pas à l'année sur l'île des
loisirs on a un magnifique ventriglisse
on a dû de l'archerie taquine sort de
deux tir à l'arc paint ball c'est en
toute sécurité
bien sûr oui on a testé les premières
les premières sessions hier et ça a
énormément plu franc succès on a rempli
tous les créneaux
il ya aussi du beach rugby du volet du
s'emballe encore handball sur sable du
bubble foot d un petit challenge foot
aussi en rapport avec le rhône qu'il ya
vraiment des tonnes tonne d'activités à
pratiquer le village sportif c'est donc
pour tous les jeunes de 11 à 17 ans et
ça dure jusqu'au 9 août
tout à fait mais alors à quoi tu es bien
sûr y est toujours et les activités pour
tous publics on retrouve la voix le
stand up paddle
voilà donc nouvelle activité sur le
centre de voile le stand up paddle gris
qui cartonne sur toutes les plages du
littoral qu'on a mis en place chez nous
on voit quelques images c'est vraiment
une façon très très détente de découvrir
les temps avec un point de vue un peu
plus haut que quand kanu et du coup ça
permet d'approcher notamment
suffisamment loin quand même mais la
réserve naturelle qui est protégé ça
permet d'aller au board de la digue qui
date de louis xiv donc vraiment
d'apprendre en cinq minutes on a honoré
si un accord a pigé le truc des balades
équestres également oui oui qu'on ait un
niveau complètement débutants ou qu'on
est à un galop 7 pour ceux qui s'y
connaissent alors on peut vraiment faire
des balades à travers à travers toute la
nature les espaces boisés au bord de
l'étang et c'est une belle façon si tu
décrire les deux préservateur de poneys
et de chevaux et également de
l'accrobranche ça ça cartonne sa
marchette gars chez vous ça marche
toujours aussi bien on a 300 personnes
par jour d'ailleurs un petit conseil
venait plus tôt le matin parce que
vraiment les après midi sont bien
remplies mais c'est vrai que l on a
quatre parcours plus un parcours pour
les 3 6 ans donc en toute sécurité sans
baudrier m'avaient confié de protection
évidemment trois parcours suivant les
niveaux
les sportifs s'y retrouve comme les
amateurs qui préfèrent plus de la
découverte en hauteur exactement et même
ceux qui ont un peu peur du vide il ya
un premier parcours qui à deux mètres du
sol ça permet quand même de faire du
petit parcours
enchaîner mais tout en étant mais par
contre le mans il est vraiment très
physique
alors il est jusqu'à 18 mètres de
hauteur et il commence à être attiré un
peu il ya quinze ateliers en breton au
parcours donc si on a enchaîné le
parcours rouge et le parcours noir
normalement les sportifs devraient s'y
retrouver alors qu'at t il ya également
des événements ponctuels plus
particuliers comme le bateau le bateau
c'est ce week end
oui c'est un non dit mardi prochain donc
c'est le badminton tour donc les bat
tours donc c'est le comité départemental
de badminton qui qui met en place cette
activité sur sur toute la région ile de
france et donc ils vont avoir de grosses
machines avec notamment un lanceur
automatique de volant qui peut lancer
une cadence infernale des volants que
les jeunes devront essayer de rattraper
et de relancer et un autre événement qui
rencontre un franc succès c'est le judo
tour tâter à partir du 18 tout à fait 18
19 et 20 juillet le judo tour donc
accessible à tous à partir de 6 ans il
sera placé au sein de l'espace
événementiel également donc ceux de
l'ancienne piscine avec qui et qui est
désormais fermé alors fermé mais
transformée en espace événementiel oui
tout à fait
là la hauteur des travaux a pas permis
de rouvrir la piscine en tant qu espace
baignade
maintenant c'est pas un équipement qu'on
a laissé mourir parce que du coup on l'a
on à habiter autrement
donc aujourd'hui on a cet espace
événementiel qui sert à la fois à des à
des entreprises le reste de l'année et
aux jeunes les théâtrales un village
pensent-ils d'été par exemple et à
l'arrière de jeux pour les enfants
jusqu'à 12 ans elle devait elle aurait
dû être ouverte par rapport aux
inondations il ya eu des petits retards
sur le chantier mais ça va s'ouvrir ça
va s'ouvrir l'air de jeux d'eau donc de
0 à 12 ans avec qui remplace l'ancienne
pataugeoire pour ceux qui l'ont connu
donc il ya plein de jeux des dragon qui
crache de l'aude et des coccinelles qui
jette de l'eau également donc ça va
vraiment être une aire très agréable
jusqu'à 300 personnes par jour voilà
donc qui était prévu pour la fin juillet
vincent courtois juifs fin juillet on
n'a pas de date précise mais à fin
juillet ce sera sur le site internet est
alors pour encore mieux diriger
justement vers toutes les activités
attractives ya toute une signalétique
qui vient d'être changé et qui s'est
installé sur la base de loisirs je vous
disais loisirs sur l'it de loisirs merci
exactement on est resté quelques mois
sans panneau donc c'était assez étonnant
puisque et plus aucun panneau sur l'île
de loisirs mais là pour le coup on a une
toute nouvelle signalétique avec des
pétales des sortes de plantes qui
sortent comme ça au milieu de nulle part
et puis qu'indique le tour de l'étang
les différentes activités
vous vous y retrouverez mieux désormais
sur l'île de loisirs donc vraiment plus
aucune raison pour ne plus se rendre à
lille et loisirs et profiter de toutes
ces activités
merci à vous trois pour la présentation
des activités estivales qui vont animer
tout saint-quentin-en-yvelines cet été
et on poursuit avec une exposition sur
le travail du photographe laurent moreau
à la galerie d'art ici ailleurs à
versailles depuis le 21 juin l'artiste
propose de s'immiscer dans le monde
animalier avec l'exposition émotions
animal le globe-trotter habitué aux
paysages colorés s'est concentrée sur un
style spécifique pour cette fois le
sépia
l'air émerveillé presque aillerie c'est
à se demander ce que regarder cette
lionne pour avoir ce regard si
particulier
laurent moreau présente son exposition
émotions animal à la galerie d'art ici
et ailleurs à versailles ce choix
diffèrent de son travail habituel le
globe trotter est coutumier des modèles
humains et des couleurs ici le
photographe n'a fait ces photos quand
c'est bien c'est vraiment un choix
artistique et le rapprochement et de
dégager une certaine émotion dans ces
cesu animaux que je que j'espère presque
l'humain l'artiste se décrit comme un
passeur d'émotions
il a figé ces regards grâce à un
téléobjectif très puissant en se
rapprochant au maximum des bêtes pour
cette exposition la fête une série tout
à fait particulière qui a été initié à
pompe
après un premier voyage au botswana où
j'ai voulu prendre des photos un petit
peu particulière des animaux avec des
émotions beaucoup plus vous voyez par
exemple ici on est on est des portraits
très très très rapprochée de 2,2
le lyon ou de l'yonne voilà donc j'ai ce
que j'ai voulu c'est vraiment redonné
une une façon de voir un petit peu
différente pour les animaux en mémoire
de son grand-père l'artiste s'est tourné
vers le sépia un hommage que laurent
moreau partagera dans la galerie d'art
tout l'été jusqu'au 30 septembre et pour
la rubrique cinéphiles on retrouve vos
avis sur les films à l'affiché cette
semaine c'était un beau film sur la
nature les paysages les animaux vos
rapports des animaux avec l'homme
surtout d'aller le voir au cinéma savons
bien sûr vente écran franchement moi
j'ai pas du tout une machine bah le
premier je les trouvais beaucoup plus
marrant je suis là j'ai trouvé un peu
grossier et ce qui attise était pas moi
il était un peu grossier et papa de ne
pas originaux en fait j'ai bien aimé est
un fin c'était marrant et on s'est bien
amusé j'étais un peu sceptique j'ai
suivi monsieur et au final un bon coup
de coeur mon coeur j'ai pas vu le temps
passer
le jeu des acteurs est très bien et puis
tarzan et agréable à voir et pour le
coup de coeur de professionnels cette
semaine c'est fear et la date du cinéma
philippe noiret des clayes sous bois
cette semaine notre coup de coeur est
tout de suite maintenant de pascal
bonitzer avec agathe bonitzer lambert
wilson et vincent lacoste n'aura sator
jeune trentenaire dynamique commencé sa
carrière dans la haute finance et quand
elle apprend que son patron et sa femme
ont fréquenté son père dans leur
jeunesse
elle découvre qu'une mystérieuse
rivalité les opposent encore sur un
scénario très élaborés et totalement
maîtrisé pascal bonitzer réunit une
formidable bande d'acteurs dans ce qui
ressemble à son meilleur long métrage
en effet le film permet à agathe
bonitzer et vincent lacoste de révéler
avec virtuosité les rôles qui leur ont
été confiées
lambert wilson manipulateurs comme jean
pierre bacri bourgon rejoue une
partition qu'ils ont interprété à
maintes reprise et le font toujours
aussi bien c'est un des charmes du film
le réalisateur parvient à ficeler une
intrigue solide autour de la notion de
faux semblants le film superbement écrit
et interprété il réduira à n'en pas
douter le spectateur tout de suite et
maintenant et à découvrir cette semaine
à l'espace philippe le ray
j'espérais tueur est votre ambition dans
la vie que le faire du fric dream boîte
de finances que mater sur ce point comme
sur tous les autres font 50 perd ça avec
intelligence
en fait j'ai une super carte four four
et avant de refermer cette émission deux
informations culturelles les trois
oeuvres de l'artiste saint quentinois
nicolas scènes sont bien installés dans
le jardin du foirail du musée soulagés
de rodez
elles sont présentées jusqu'au 16
octobre et enfin vous pourrez soutenir
les bleus pour la finale de l'euro 2016
qui les oppose au portugal au centre
sportif pierre de coubertin de montigny
le bretonneux dimanche soir à 21h le
match sera retransmis sur grand écran et
l'entrée est gratuite
et c'est la fin de cette émission vous
pourrez la retrouver
la voir et la revoir sur notre site
internet pour ma part je vous souhaite
un excellent week end